welcome to the short week everybody
Thanksgiving week as we get geared up
for the holidays and I know a lot of
people only have the only have the three
days to work this week which means that
you know and your boss will understand
this there's really no reason to do
anything at your job because you only
got three days and so you can't start
anything you won't be able to finish it
better to come back next week and really
get down to work you know what I mean
what's really every week can sort of
work that way if you're good at being
lazy because you figure your wake up on
a Monday and you say well it's the week
just started I'm getting into into the
into the into the groove of things I'm
not really gonna do anything today and
then on Tuesday the week's still kind of
starting then a Wednesday you wake up
and you figure well the weeks almost
over so I might as well just wait till
next week and that's when I'll really
get down to business
but anyway it's Thanksgiving of course
the second-best holiday on the calendar
and well maybe that depends because I
just saw this article in The Daily wire
headline pretty horrific headline is
studies show that few people actually
fight with family over politics on
Thanksgiving few people actually fight
with family over politics and then the
article says studies show that few
Americans argue on Thanksgiving they
prefer to practice that age-old axiom
agree to disagree as they enjoy another
slice of that delicious pecan pie in
reality very few Americans actually
fight about politics on Thanksgiving
notes Abraham Gutman of the Philadelphia
Inquirer
a 20-17 HuffPost YouGov survey found
that only 3% of Americans so that they
are very likely and 8% are somewhat
likely to get into a political argument
with family members during Thanksgiving
dinner and I read this I just think how
utterly boring my god I mean what kind
of a boring family do you have that you
don't argue about politics and religion
on Thanksgiving I know people always say
are the two things you don't talk about
with family or ever are politics and
Thanksgiving and religion but I've
always had a slight variation on that
which is you know my axiom is the only
two things you talk about our politics
and religion and sports I guess we'll
throw in the third thing basically
anything that has the potential to turn
into a screaming match is worth talking
about and if it doesn't have that
potential I don't what what's the
point um you know III don't even
understand it I just can't imagine
getting together with family and
specifically avoiding the interesting
topics what are you even doing what do
you talk about in that case you just sit
there this
cranberry sauce tastes like cranberries
yes it does yes I also agree it does
when you go around the table yes what do
you think about the cranberry sauce well
I think it tastes like cranberries and
then someone kind of a loose cannon
comes in what about the mashed potatoes
well I think they taste like potatoes
yes me too me too
yes I agree then you have the comic
relief what if green beans were red
hahahaha
humorous quite humorous hi this has
become a fake conversation between
Androids apparently but that's I just
can't know I've been at a dinner table
in my life a time or two we're all
interesting topics politics and religion
were forbidden and I just wanted to
drown myself in the gravy boat that's
what I wanted to do just just start
waterboarding myself with gravy to liven
things up and to put me out of my misery
now if I were to do that at my
Thanksgiving table it would just start a
three and a half hour debate about the
ethics of an enhanced interrogation
while I lay there dead on the floor and
see that's what family is all about okay
I want to sow a bunch of things we're
going to go through today and we'll
start with this as we're a few days from
Thanksgiving and talking about football
I will begin with Harvard and Yale
playing each other this weekend in the
classic traditional game and and then
and then this happened yeah the game is
currently in a delay because there is a
student protest sit-in at midfield on
climate policy this took place at
halftime and is delayed the start of the
third quarter because students are
having a sit-in protest at midfield of
Harvard Yale yes those are climate
protesters again once again breaking the
law once again getting in the way once
again gents just generally making asses
of themselves and nuisances of
themselves every time they do something
like this they make more and more people
crave the destruction of planet Earth so
it's it's really counterproductive in so
many ways in this case they delayed the
game for over an hour
which is a big problem actually Yale
because the the stadium there doesn't
have lights and so they end up finishing
the game in near darkness with no lights
the protesters were eventually
apparently assured off the field after
an hour some who refused to leave were
arrested which is good that they've
lived like 20 or 30 people were arrested
I've been waiting for there to be mass
arrests at these things and finally they
do it but once again I have to have to
ask what why wait an hour why let this
go on for now why aren't
why aren't the police there in in in 15
seconds why give them an hour to just
get it to just shut the game down that's
what I don't get just show up right away
and start dragging their butts off the
field that's all you have to do if
they're blocking traffic just right away
come and drag them off what why wait why
give it now give them a little game
about an hour to do this yeah why not
since when is that okay especially these
days with the with the focus on security
at these kinds of events and you're just
letting people camp out on the field for
an hour now if it were me I would have I
would have started the second half
because they came out at halftime stayed
for an hour so if I was in charge I
would have said just start the game
start the game if the cops aren't gonna
drag him off the field just start the
game with them on the field kick the
ball off and run right through them and
it would have I would have done in fact
it would have looked something like this
[Music]
lockers along the sideline
probaly
[Applause]
sensational dramatic now that would be
entertainment if you can imagine that
same play and that call except with
climate change protesters getting
trampled instead of instead of instead
of a marching band now that would be
entertainment as I said but in a way I
guess I'm glad that these climate
protesters have taken it to this level
in a way I'm glad that they're
interrupting football games I hope they
take it down south next because they're
all you know it's one thing if you're at
ivy league and you're doing this but I
hope that they take it down south and
try it at college games down there
because this is really the last straw
that will officially turn everybody
against them you want to interrupt
traffic and make me late for work and
get me fired that's one thing you start
messing with my football and now we've
got serious problems there are some
lines you just don't cross in America
and and I think this is one of them and
but this I think is the fatal flaw with
these climate protestors there well the
first fatal flaw is that they're
protesting the climate which there's
very little chance of that having any
effect okay it's like if there was a you
know that you have a drought and so you
go and interrupt a football game to
protest the drought which is basically
what they're doing it's the same idea
it's probably not I mean you're not
going to convince the weather to change
its mind because they read your signs
but the other problem is that there are
sensibly trying to save humanity in
their minds anyway but they hate
humanity
that's the one thing that jumps out at
you and you when you see them doing this
stuff they just have a total contempt
for normal people and and they don't
mind getting in our way and screwing
things up for us that's why they're not
they're not doing things to interfere
with billionaires and the evil
corporations and all of that they're not
impeding on the dreaded rich they're not
doing that they're shutting down traffic
during rush hour they're stopping trains
from from running they're delaying
football games these are tactics aimed
totally at normal working-class people
all everything they're doing is aimed
square at us it's like they think
they'll solve climate change by annoying
the hell out of middle-class people and
I'm not sure I see the connection there
but but that's what this is and and and
but but I think that's because this
isn't really about solving anything this
is about their general contempt for
people and for Western civilization and
their need for attention that's what
this is really about now before we move
on actually I have to I want to give a
salute to somebody since we're on this
topic all right I got it a Twitter
message direct message yesterday from
somebody last night it goes by the name
Jay Russell and this is the message that
he sent me it says hi do you have a
second to talk I was a vendor at the
harvard-yale game who lost a lot of
revenue because of the protest I saw a
lot of inside info about what happened
if you want it and so I got this did I
get messages like this a lot when
there's something in the news and
somebody was personally affected by it
and they'll send me a message saying hey
I know something about this or I've got
a perspective and so I sent him a
message back like I do for for anybody
and I said can you tell me over message
what happened I'm interested to hear and
then and then this is what he responded
with of course thank you so much I was
selling food just by the entrance of the
Yale Stadium but since the game got
delayed I didn't have enough heat / cash
to sell through the entire time I'm mad
as hell but I heard some students
talking by my stand right before and
during the protest they were saying
things like don't start until we get the
OK from Joe and stay there until Joe
gives the single signal so it seems like
this guy was pretty central to the whole
thing and then Irish
on it with do you know who Joe is and
then this guy says Joe mama did that was
it that was he was setting me up for
that the entire time and the thing is I
clicked on this guy's profile
he made this account this fake account
just so he could message me and he went
through that whole long story just to
hit me with the jomama the end and I I
respect it I really do salute to that
guy that is I respect a good troll game
and that's that's pretty good and I fell
right for it some people are saying that
I should have fallen for I you know I
where's the red flag on maybe when he
starts getting into the Joe thing but he
just sees semi he lulled me into a
feeling of confidence and then he hit me
with it
so that's good stuff all right let's go
to wanted to mention this quickly Rick
Perry is getting a lot of grief today on
social media and and by the mass media
for something you said on Fox News about
Donald Trump so take a listen
God's used imperfect people all through
history King David wasn't perfect Saul
wasn't perfect Solomon wasn't perfect
and I actually gave the president a
little one-pager on those Old Testament
Kings about a month ago and I shared it
with him I said mr. president I know
there are people that say you know you
said you were the chosen one and and I
said you were I said if you're a
believing Christian you understand God's
plan for the people who rule and and and
and judge over us on this planet in our
in our government and so people are
people are making fun of this and look
I'm not a I'm I'm not a fan of the
Donald Trump King David comparisons I'll
say that one it's it's tired and played
out to Trump is not a king three there
really is no similarity that I can see
I've ameliorating David I don't really
see any similarity at all between him
and Donald Trump aside from the adultery
thing but with that said I want to stick
up for Perry here and and I and I think
the
reaction to this as people are attacking
him for saying Trump is the chosen one
the reaction shows again how the media
fails to understand basic Christian
theology and Christian thought and so
they're always embarrassing themselves
in an effort to embarrass Christians
because they don't understand
Christianity which is a pretty big flaw
if your work for the news media and you
don't understand this system of thought
this religion this philosophy that the
majority of people in your in the
country ascribe to so Perry is not
saying despite the King David comparison
Perry is not saying that Trump is a
messianic figure or a prophet or
anything like that he's simply saying
that
our leaders are in some sense appointed
by God that it's all in God's will so
whoever's in charge is there according
to God's will that's his point that's
what he say and as he apparently also
said Obama Obama was appointed by God as
well for his time and for the reasons
God had in mind now you don't have to
agree with this and if you aren't a
Christian you probably won't but that is
the Christian approach the Christian
philosophy on these things that this is
all in God's will and that God and that
leaders are there because they're
ordained by God to be there this is this
is scriptural it's in the Bible st.
Paul's pretty explicit by this about
this now
I would agree that among the Morphin
Trump fans there's been a messianic sort
of flavor to their Trump support but
that again is on the fanatic extremes
and it is gross it's on American it's
unbiblical it's pathetic it's
blasphemous it's idol-worshipping it's a
disgrace to see anyone make a messiah
out of a political figure I'm totally
opposed to that I hate it it disgusts me
yet the same was done in this is the
point the same was done on the fanatic
extremes of Obama's support how quickly
that's forgotten so I think what we're
seeing now with Obama and now with Trump
is the beginning of a new era a new
trend in American politics of on the
extreme ends turning our political years
into prophets and messiahs now that's
not I say new that's not a certainly not
a new thing in world history and it's I
wouldn't even call it unnecessarily a
totally new thing in American history
there are people that did that with you
know JFK but people didn't really do
that with Bush okay there was no there
was no Messiah Complex with Bush to
where people doing that I don't think
people really do that with Clinton so if
you want to call it a resurgence or
something we are seeing that now for
people forgetting that these are just
bureaucrats they aren't monarchs they're
really supposed to be our employees
they're supposed to work for us
that's the attitude we're supposed to
have about them and this is why I go on
all the time about how I don't think
politicians should have fans I don't
think you should be a fan of a
politician you want to be a supporter
fine but you're you're a supporter and
it's a very conditional support as long
as they're doing things that you think
are right then you support them while
they do those things but if they do
things you don't think are right then
you criticize them and so we should all
be Fairweather supporters when it comes
to politicians this stuff you hear
sometimes about I'm loyal T no we don't
have loyalty to politicians in this
country we have loyalty to the flag we
have loyalty to the country we have
loyalty to each other to our families to
our friends we should not be loyal to
politicians what's up that's a bad move
and that's not just a phenomenon on the
right or on the Left it's on both and I
find it equally disturbing on both ends
and it's interesting that in the media
they've noticed some of this on the
fringes of trumps support and now they
have a problem with it when they were
the ones doing it themselves when it was
Obama but again that's not what brick
Perry's talking about here that's not
how I read it the Perry clip is not an
example of that he's just talking about
what the Bible says about about our
political leaders the people who say
that Trump is going to single-handedly
save America or he is single-handedly
saving America people who fawn over him
at rallies like he's like he's the
Beatles and they're teenagers in the
1960s that would be an example of the
Messianic stuff for sure but I don't
think that's what I see here okay let's
go back to a theme we've talked about a
lot on this show especially recently but
I need to revisit it again because this
story just cannot be ignored and
gonna read to you here fair warning is
very disturbing also graphic so if you
just be prepared for that all right this
is from the Daily Mail says children as
young as six are being taught about
touching or stimulating their own
genitals as part of classes that will
become compulsory in hundreds of primary
schools some parents believe the lessons
part of a controversial new sex in
relationships teaching program called
all about me are sexualizing they're
young children one couple told last
night how they are so disturbed they
withdrew their sons from lessons at a
school where the program is already
being taught all about me is being
rolled out across across 241 primaries
and could be adopted by other local
authorities next year as part of the
government's overhaul of relationship
and sex education so this is this is not
in the United States this is the UK
family campaigners and religious groups
warned that vague guidelines issued by
the department of education meant
schools could soon be providing sexual
material to young children that many
parents would consider inappropriate
and then it goes on I recommend going
DailyMail looking up this article it
says under a section called touching
myself teachers are advised to tell
teach children that lots of people like
to tickle or stroke themselves as it
might feel nice they're also instructed
to inform youngsters that this may
include touching their private parts and
that while some people may say this
behavior is dirty it is in fact very
normal however the youngsters are warned
it is not polite to touch themselves in
public okay as we get that concession at
least it is an activity that should do
be done alone in the bath shower or in
bed and the same lesson children are
given scenarios which they must judge to
be okay or not okay and one pupils are
told that when a girl called autumn has
a bath and is alone she likes to touch
herself between her legs it feels nice
at this point teachers are advised to
remind the students of the rules about
self stimulation
oh my gosh
like I can't even read anymore of this I
just like I said Daily Mail it a couple
other outlets have picked it up now
I'm not gonna repeat everything I've
said it recently in general about the
efforts to sexualize our children and
normalize pedophilia which is what this
is in fact this isn't this isn't this is
not just the gradual normalization of
pedophilia
sorry fact I would not call this
necessarily the normalization of
pedophilia
this is pedophilia that that's this
isn't like the lead up to it okay we're
not on the slippery slope on the way to
it this is this is it any teacher or
administrator who teaches a lesson like
this is sexually abusing children and is
therefore in my opinion guilty of
pedophilia they're pedophiles perhaps
not in a legal sense because the law is
screwed up but the fact of what they're
actually doing can't be avoided you
aren't you are sexually preying upon
children you are grooming them the fact
that you're doing it in school as part
of the lesson plan makes no difference
and for any teacher who says well I have
no choice but to give the lesson plan
well that gets into this I was following
orders thing that that excuse only gets
you so far
and there are times in life when you
don't follow orders and if the orders
are go and participate in the sexual
abuse of children then your moral duty
is to say no if you lose your job over
that fine
so in my opinion this is just
straight-up pedophilia plain and simple
now this is not happening yet in the
United States this is across the pond
but we know that Europe is just a true
it is just a few train cars ahead of us
on on the train to crazytown it's not
even like they're in a whole separate
train there they're on the same train
just a few cars up from us so wherever
they are now we soon will be and why
will we be there because for one thing
this is a natural consequence of our
whole approach to sex ed with kids in
school this is why I've always said
there should not be sex ed classes at
school we get into the debate about
should there be abstinence education or
safe sex that night
how about neither ok we shouldn't do
either one of those things that's the
wrong question it's a false choice you
want to teach kids about Anatomy fine go
ahead you want to teach them in them the
basic biological facts of human
reproduction this is how babies are made
etc then great yeah of course you're
gonna teach that that's science that's
fine but it shouldn't go beyond that
there's no reason to go beyond that
it's not the school's job to take it
beyond that it's not their business
because anything beyond the basic facts
of human reproduction anything outside
of that gets into opinions and value
systems it gets into the schools the
teachers personal and ideological views
about human sexuality and really might
even go it gets even past that in some
of these cases it sounds like we're
getting into their into their fetishes
but whatever it is it's it's their
personal perspective as demented and
dark and and disturbing as that
perspective is getting into what people
should do what they shouldn't do what's
normal what isn't why in god's name
should we accept or allow the schools to
give those opinion those kinds of
opinions to our kids these kinds of
opinion based lectures on sexuality
whoo-hoo who would have ever thought
that this is appropriate what good
argument is there for it and you might
say well the schools have to do it cuz
the parents aren't doing it well first
of all the
is the problem that yes what what what
the what this curriculum says to kids
it's true that a lot of parents aren't
saying it because they shouldn't be okay
if you're not a degenerate demian
predator you're not going to say that
stuff to your child
you see that's the issue when you get
into well we have two schools have to do
it cuz the parents are doing it it's
your opinion that it should be done at
all so it would be like if I said well
you know there's a problem and this
parents aren't bringing their kids up in
the faith and so teachers need to stand
up there and say Jesus Christ is your
Lord and Savior repent and believe the
left would go insane there would be
cries of child abuse and they would say
it's unconstitutional it's oppressive
it's wrong there's no place for in the
school and I couldn't say well the
parents aren't doing it because the
answer would be well who says it needs
to be done and besides it's not for the
schools to do and in fact I would agree
now I wouldn't agree that that's abusive
or oppressive it wouldn't be morally to
based the way that this sex ed thing is
but it would be wrong you know as a
Christian I would say it's it's not for
it it's not a teacher's job it's not the
place it's not the time for for them to
get up there and in a preach like that
now I think you want to teach the Bible
as a matter of history and literature
then I absolutely think that that should
be taught in school it's the most
influential piece of writing ever
compiled and so obviously it should be
taught but in terms of your personal
views on religion no you're not you're
not passing that on to the kids it's not
your job same with this
and preach the gospel of Jesus Christ
then they also shouldn't get up there
and preach the gospel of modern sexual
enlightenment that's not okay either
it's not the teachers place to share her
religious views and it's not her place
to share her views on sexuality and if
you're taking that stuff out of it
taking all the opinion-based stuff out
if you're taking all the value-based
stuff out you're taking all that's
ideological out and you're saying the
schools have no place there then you've
really you've dismantled sex ed there's
no place for sex ed anymore which which
is exactly the point because everything
that's left is stuff that you could
teach in science class
that's that those are things that belong
in biology and Anatomy
and we should do that I'm not saying
that the school should tell you no sixth
graders that babies come from storks
that drop them on the doorstep I'm not
saying that
a huge vast chasm that separates this is
how babies are made from let's teach
kids about masturbation and not only
teach them about it but encourage them
to do it
but this is where we're headed we really
are and I've been look I've been beating
this drum about the sexualization of
children the normalization of pedophilia
and I've been talking about this and I'm
not the only one but those of us who
have been talking about it we've been
told for years that you're exaggerating
you're it's it's not that bad you're
being dramatic
and look at what's happened while we've
been warning about this you've got this
you've got the you know the drag queen
story hours that are come popular we've
got child drag queens dancing at gay
bars I mean in dozens of other examples
like that
maybe eventually everybody else will
wake up and see that oh you know
actually we're not being dramatic this
is really happening
and if you want to avoid it happening in
this country and in our schools then
what that means is is not it doesn't
mean that we come in and say let's do
abstinence education no it means we say
let's not do this stuff in school at all
because actually we talk about
abstinence education now I would prefer
that obviously over this but I don't
really want the teacher but if I set my
kid to a public school which I don't but
if I did I wouldn't want their teacher
their health teacher or whoever to stand
up there and give them a speech about
the glories of abstinence I don't want
them doing that it's it's not your place
it's not none of your business I just
don't want you talking about that at all
I don't want you helping my kid avoid
having sex that to me is really weird
it's it's better intended at least than
this other stuff but it's still weird
and wrong and it's just not your place
sorry
and and the other thing is I don't trust
no offense if you work in the schools
but I don't trust you to do it I don't I
don't trust you to do a sufficient job
and because we're getting into it's a
very difficult message to relay and for
it to make it effective and to make it
resonate I just don't trust you to do it
right
so what I'm saying is butt out get the
hell out of it it's none of your damned
business just because we send this kids
to school to learn the ABCs and one
through threes and to learn you know all
the algebra and history and that it
doesn't all of a sudden mean that you
have a say in every aspect of my kid's
life
why would it mean that
all right let's move on to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from honey says hey
Matt I Imani pregnant gives me a
pronunciation guide to pronounce that
right which I appreciate by the way a
regular watcher of your show I wanted to
thank you for dedicating several
valuable minutes of your podcasts
regularly to defend the innocents and
safety of our children be james-younger
drag queen book reading sessions and
public libraries or the issue of
permitting biological boys into the
female changing room in school thank you
for fighting what really matters to
people like me
far too many conservative podcasts focus
on the bigger issues all the time like
elections impeachment and Medicare for
all I sometimes feel that the focus on
the big issues takes attention away from
the issues that affect us most I'm not a
father I'm not married but I hope to
experience the joy of being a father one
day at me people like you defend our
children gladdens my heart and makes me
look forward to being a father one day I
hope to be half as good as you are well
thank you first of all I I think there
are many people you could look to for
examples on how to be a great father I
wouldn't necessarily look to me I'm
still still figuring that out for myself
in many ways but thanks for saying that
and I appreciate it I do here come and
I'll tell you why I appreciate it
because I do hear complaints from people
sometimes that I don't talk enough about
politics I don't talk about Pietschmann
really know these as you say bigger
broader issues and and I don't because
first of all I figure you're hearing
enough about that everywhere else you go
literally anywhere to hear analysis on
that and some of the analysis is very
good but you've probably heard it
already by the time you get to me and
also for me those just aren't the issues
that I find to be the most important or
the most interesting and I don't think
they're the most relevant to your life I
don't think most people when you wake up
in the morning I don't think you're
worrying about impeachment I don't think
your first thought is about the
President or Nancy Pelosi or a
politician I hope it isn't right
probably if you're a parent for instance
you wanted your first thoughts about
your kids and one of the worries that
you have when you wake up in the morning
and when you're go to bed is about the
culture that your kids are inheriting
and stuff like
so that's that's what I find it be the
most part and you say you say that
impeachment and everything those are the
bigger issues I know what you mean by
that
but I think just to clarify for
everybody else and I don't want to speak
for you but I I think what you mean is
bigger in the sense of broader those are
the the broader issues and they are but
I don't think they're bigger and it
sounds like you would agree they're not
bigger in terms of importance
and so in a way I think that I do try to
focus on the bigger issues in terms of
the ones that are more important and
more relevant to our lives okay this is
from Eric says greetings oh great one I
humbly approach you and I'm seeking
justice in this cruel world I have been
wronged I hope that under your rule the
world would be a better and more just
place I'm writing to see if there will
be a law against such atrocities under
your great rule I regret to inform you
that after pumping gas at a local gas
station I returned to my car like
nothing had happened upon entering my
car I noticed a distinct smell I came to
realize that my hand had been coated in
someone's cologne from previous pumping
I find this absolutely unacceptable and
wonder what a punishment could be for
such a horrible act I'm not sure if this
is a larger problem across America or
just a local one as I live on Long
Island so someone who either themselves
with colognes so thick that it rubbed
off on a gas pump and you could smell
that over the gasoline there's no reason
to punish that person I'll just say
they've already probably suffocated from
their own fumes or suffered brain damage
which will maybe explain a lot over over
up there on Long Island I don't know so
this is one of those self punishing
infractions I would say but I'm sorry
you had to go through that dear glorious
leader this is from Simon with all the
rules you have talked about about about
chilly on your show with all the times
you talk about it chilly on your show I
don't think you've ever given a ruling
on whether chili dogs are appropriate
which seems like a big oversight as the
theocratic chili authority how do you
feel about them how does cheese play in
this is one of those questions that
haunts me frankly and I did avoid it I
got a few emails about it and I decided
to finally just answer it on the one
hand I enjoyed chili dogs on the other
hand can you make the case that putting
chili on a hot dog is an act of
desecration I think you could is it not
blasphemous to treat chili like a mere
condiment so I settle on a compromise
Simon died I say that I look at it like
this if you're gonna dump a $90 if
you're gonna put red wine in your pasta
sauce you're not gonna put a $90 bottle
of wine and pasta sauce right you're
gonna put a put of seven dollar bottle
of red wine you picked up you know the
bottom rack
at the liquor store into the red wine
into the into the pasta sauce and you
aren't and under my regime this will be
a matter of law but you're not gonna
take a high quality bourbon like
Woodford double oak or Blanton's or
Baker's or or even for rows of single
barrel and put coke in it you know put
soda you're not gonna do that you're
gonna drink it neat you're gonna drink
it with ice those are the two
appropriate ways to drink it and so I
think it's the same thing with chili and
hot dogs if it's if it is a if it's real
chili if it's good chili and you put it
put it on a hot dog then that of course
would be treasonous and you would be
deserving of and in fact will receive
death for that but if it's if we're
talking about canned chili or some some
abomination like that
or let's say in fact you're at someone's
house and they serve your chili and they
put the chili down in front of you and
you look at it and you see black beans
and you see corn and you see way too
much tomato sauce tomatoes in there you
know so it's like this tomato based corn
and bean soup that they're trying to
pretend is chili in that case then what
you would say that person is please
bring me a hot dog because what you've
given me here is a bowl of a condiment
this is not a meal so give me a hot dog
so I can have a real meal
do that or get the hell out of my house
even though it's not your houses there's
but you can kick them out of their own
house for that and then burn it to the
ground you know and I think that that
would not be an overreaction at all
finally from Emily says hi Matt I agree
with you on the trans bathroom issue but
what about someone who is completely
transitioned what about a male the
transitions to a woman and gets the
surgery and everything and is living
full-time as a female don't you think
it's reasonable to allow them into the
women's facility in their case at least
wouldn't it be kind of cruel to force
them into the men's room yeah I the way
that I look at this two points first of
all if somebody does that to their body
that is their choice in many ways and so
I don't think we need to reorganize
society to accommodate that probably a
better choice would be to not do that to
yourself but it's also kind of
irrelevant because if someone does go
the whole nine yards with the sex
transition thing and they're living as
you say full-time as a woman and they
look the part nearly then it's it's not
an issue because nobody could tell the
difference right so if you're really
living that way and and and pulling it
off then no one can tell the difference
and we don't need to change the rules
because there's no issue so I understand
what you're saying and I've got a lot of
emails people asking about this well
what about but that is exactly where you
don't really have an issue because
nobody would know it's only an issue
when when it's when everyone can tell
that's when it becomes an issue and
that's when you have just dudes who are
they got all the parts of dudes and they
look like dudes and everything and
they're just waltzing into the women's
room so when we start changing laws and
policies it is specifically for those
dudes
because this other category you're
talking about I guess for them they're
not really having much of a problem
because nobody knows now what do i
personally think I what's my personal
view my personal view is if you're a
male you use the men's room no matter
what you look like and if you've gotten
surgery you're still a man so you're
still belong in the men's room you're a
woman surgery or not you're still
blowing a woman's room but my point is
in terms of practically speaking in
terms of everyday practice I guess that
wouldn't really come up because nobody
would know okay I think we'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed Matt Walsh show is produced by
Sean Hampton executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Donovan Fowler audio mixer Mike
Cora Mina the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show the
impeachment hearings were full of
explosive devastating bombshells like
the fact that we're being governed by a
sinister cabal of deep state bureaucrats
who think they can overrule our elected
representatives so what do the Democrats
do now poor things all the experts say
they'll impeach and maybe so but they're
Daisy's if they do I'll talk about it on
the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew clay